le choix ce soir soit la polémique entre
didier rahout et les hôpitaux de paris
soit celle entre roselyne bachelot et
les médecins libéraux
alors on a déjà parlé didier raoul temps
vous propose donc d'écouter roselyne
bachelot j'ai entendu un représentant
d'un syndicat de médecins dire nous
n'avions pas de masque dans nos cabinets
m'enfin des médecins qui n'ont pas de
masque dans leurs cabinets qui se
constitue pas un stock
nous n'avions pas de blues mais enfin
pourquoi les médecins ne porte plus de
blues
qu'est ce que c'est que cette dent pays
de pasteur qu'est ce que c'est que cette
médecine mais enfin on attend que le
préfet ou le directeur de la rs viennent
avec une petite charrette porter des
masques
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays
infantiliser il faut quand même un peu
se prendre en main dans ce pays
alors les médecins dénoncent ces propos
il rappelle les médecins libéraux en
tous les cas il rappelle le sacrifice
d'une cinquantaine d'entre eux qui sont
morts dus coronavirus après avoir été
après avoir été contaminée on vous pose
la question sur twitter roselyne
bachelot at elle raison de dénoncer
l'attitude des médecins sur la pénurie
de masques et de blues
alors vous a posé la question un petit
peu tard donc vous pouvez continuer à y
répondre on va en débattre
pour l'instant vous êtes partagés sur la
sur la réponse il ya légère majorité qui
répond non mais
vous êtes vous êtes vous êtes partagés
vous êtes pète surtout pas été nombreux
à voter donc vous pouvez continuer à
voter il ya ce commentaire de david qui
nous dit mettre sur le dos des hôpitaux
la gestion de leur propre stock de
masques était une mesure budgétaire
continue à diminuer le budget alloué à
la santé chaque année par la suite est
un non sens et pas que pour cette raison
la santé devrait être étrangère à la
rentabilité et libertariens va plus loin
vous nous dites ces propos sont comptées
plusieurs mois d'appels de détresse des
pros de la santé et rien sérieusement 40
pros qui ont voué leur vie pour les
autres sont décédés en a même on parle
même de 50 nord est
il donc il estime que roselyne bachelot
devrait être à la retraite et il dit
également on reparle des sacs poubelle
comme comme blues ferghana ziari si vous
m'entendez
moi j'avais une autre question à
linverse finalement quand on entend
heureusement mme bachelot son discours
est assez libérale non nos internes aux
intervenants ne nous entendent pas
encore on va continuer à donner vos
propos il y a lisbeth qui nous dit et
que dire de l'inflation lamentable du
prix des équipements sur les
professionnels de santé
on enverrait sur le front des soldats
qui devraient se procurer dehors des
prix à prix d'or leur propre fusil calé
légitimité de cet ex ministre a apporté
la moindre critique elle dont la
réussite à ce poste n'est pas une
certitude si ce n'est celle d'une
utilisation excessive des deniers
publics pour une protection inutilisés
alors il paraît que de nouveau nos
intervenants un m'entendent et vont nous
sortir de ce moment de solitude dans
laquelle je commence à mieux et j'étais
pas très content d'être aussi autant
isolé un peu mal à l'aise mais je repose
donc la question à ferghana ziari
finalement ces propos de roselyne
bachelot peut-être que vous ne les avez
pas entendu mais on en a beaucoup parlé
depuis ce matin sont assez libéral ça
devrait vous plaire non d'un côté c'est
vrai que ces propos sont un peu
intéressant est à la fois elle est un
peu aussi gonfler si je puis dire
intéressant parce que il est vrai qu on
vit dans un pays où l'état remplacé dieu
et on attend tout de l'état c'est à dire
que le simple le simple fait de se
tordre la cheville fait que vous ensuite
vous ozap vous appelez le prétend la
république ou au secours
et c'est vrai que la culture de
l'entr'aide spontané a complètement
disparu à force de tout entendre de la
bio tout d'attendre pardon de la
bureaucratie
maintenant il faut aussi rappeler que
cette entraide spontanée elle n'a pas
été facilitée par la puissance publique
qu'on songe à la période de réquisition
des masques qui comme beaucoup de
journalistes l'ont souligné don
complètement asséché les sources
d'approvisionnement des masques entre
autres choses ce qui est renté le
travail des importateurs des
distributeurs beaucoup plus difficile
parce que tous les signaux de prix tous
les cieux marchés ont été anéantis par
cette politique soviétique de
réquisition qui soi-disant avait donc
pour objectif de juguler la pénurie
quand elle l'a aggravée donc il est vrai
que nous avons perdu cette culture de
l'autonomie mais en même temps elle n'a
pas été facilitée voire a été grandement
sa beauté pas la puissance publique en
raison de toutes les interférences qui
ont empêché finalement l'offre de
s'ajuster à la demande pendant toute
cette crise je salue nicole roland qui
nous ont rejoints sur la page d'accueil
du figaro on va donner vos commentaires
lucile vous qui m'avez dit dans un
épisode précédent dans mon avis pendant
le confinement que vous regrettiez que
les autorités ne faisait pas assez
confiance à la société civile
vous devriez d'accord quand même avec ce
que dit roselyne bachelot non le sujet
de la confiance il est posé c'est clair
qu' il y avait un côté très verticale
très d'ailleurs dans même dans le
confinement dans la méthode de
confinement
ces méthodes assez policière après dans
l'intervention de roselyne bachelot il
ya deux choses
elle dit notamment que les collectivités
locales aura dû au fond prendre
davantage leurs responsabilités vous
avez pour fournir les masques à tous les
acteurs de santé et l invite à une forme
de décentralisation qui était pas le
préfet avec sa charrette l'image
elle a un goût de l'image d'ailleurs qui
est extraordinaire en revanche je suis
très critique sur le fait qu'elle ait pu
expliquer que les médecins généralistes
les médecins de ville et est responsable
la constitution d'un stock de masques il
fallait qu'ils portent des blues etc
vous allez ses médecins ont été en
première ligne en fait face à
l'inquiétude de la société fasse aussi
au fait qu'on ne connaissait pas à
l'avance les symptômes du coronavirus
donc ils ont découvert en direct avant
même l'hôpital un certain nombre de cinq
donc je sais pas si vous vous rappelez
le feuilleton du grenelle
on nous disait ça commence par la fièvre
la respiration après on nous expliquait
qu'il y avait aussi la diarrhée puis
qu'il y avait des symptômes
dermatologiques très grave et au fond
c'est là qu'on a découvert que selon le
système immunologique de chacun de
chacun d'entre nous les symptômes
étaient différents donc je crois que ces
médecins étaient en première ligne
d'ailleurs il y en a plusieurs dizaines
qui sont morts il y en a 16 pensant
qu'ils ont été contaminés et du coup
leur renvoyer la balle alors qu'il
n'avait ni masque ni blouse en
expliquant que c'était leur
responsabilité une fois que la pandémie
était là moi je suis très critique là
dessus en revanche je pense que la
collaboration entre acteurs publics
collectivités locales et l'état aurait
dû être beaucoup plus forte et qu' il ya
eu une espèce de concentration des
pouvoirs et d'ailleurs même du côté de
l'hôpital c'était complètement hospital
au centre et on se rappelle que les
médecins généralistes existait on en n'a
pas du tout parlé vous rappeler au début
de la crise le fil on je veux pas
refaire la commission denquête mais
précisément sur ce qu'a déclaré sur ce
qu'a déclaré roselyne bachelot
quelle que soit la personnalité de
roselyne bachelot sur le fond est ce que
vous êtes d'accord ou pas d'accord avec
ce qu'elle a dit je ne suis pas d'accord
avec la critique des médecins
généralistes qu'elle a fait je suis
d'accord avec la critique qu'elle a pu
faire par rapport aux collectivités
locales c'est à dire que ce qu'on
appelle société civile
tout ce qui n'est pas l'état d'une
certaine manière je crois qu'il faut
différencier les rôles lorsque vous êtes
maire d'une grande ville
lorsque vous présidé un conseil
départemental lorsque vous êtes
responsable d'une agence régionale de
santé
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'attendre que
emmanuel macron edouard philippe olivier
vers en avait parlé pour agir donc je
pense que le sujet qui est devant nous
c'est qui est responsable qui se sent
responsable
mais je ne crois pas que dire que les
médecins de ville et est responsable du
fait de ne pas avoir de masques étaient
quelque chose enfin je pense qu'ils ont
été suffisamment première ligne face à
la pandémie
pour ne pas rajouter en rajouter en
disant oh je le rappelais ils sont morts
un donc qu' il ya il ya ils ont ils
s'étaient soigneusement une seule une
cinquantaine
certains disent carotte mais ce matin en
tous les cas le président du syndicat
des médecins libéraux lui évoqué le
chiffre de 51 si mes souvenirs sont bons
vous a mis en cause les élus locaux
alors je voudrais avoir la réaction
d'une ancienne élue locale en la
personne de céline pina en fait on a on
a peu de mémoire parce que rappelez-vous
en fait les élus locaux ont réagi on a
un certain nombre de régions qui ont
commandé des masques
rappelez-vous d'ailleurs les histoires
un peu amusantes à mon avis pas pour les
gens qui les vivent et où les régions
voyez les basques est repris par l'état
quant à eux sur le tarmac des aéroports
autant il ya les régions essayé de
réagir les 1eres peut-être que là il y
aurait une critique un peu plus forte
affirmé ce qu'elle était chargée
notamment d'urgence sanitaire est
absente dans tout le combat qu'on a dû
mener contre un abîme ans mais au-delà
de ça qu on se rappelle dans quel
contexte aux phrases solide d'effraction
dans un contexte où on sait qu'on a
envoyé des gens ou sans le minimum
nécessaire et où on a aujourd'hui des
séries politique
il nous dit tout va bien tout va très
bien tout était sous contrôle tout était
anticipée et plusieurs mois que ce parti
avait ce qu'il fallait donc c'est
forcément la faute de l'autre et on
abuse gens qui ouvrent le parapluie en
permanence mais et on peut comprendre
ils ont peur que leur père soit sur le
micro le seul problème c'est que
personne ne cherche des solutions
aujourd'hui on ne cherche pas les
éléments matériels de fait un moment
donné c'est très simple il y à l'eprus
le directeur de l'épreuve ce qui envoie
une lettre disant on a un souci de stuff
de cette lettre nul n'est capable de
dire ce qu'ils né à douai ce qu'elle a
atterri et pourquoi elle n'a déclenché
aucune réaction
moi je serais beaucoup plus intéressés à
retracer ce qui s'est passé à l'inter
d'administration à l'intérieur du
ministère de façon extrêmement factuel
et je me moque on fasse tomber des têtes
à la limite je veux bien prendre dire ok
c'est pas grave je pense que ça les mets
proposés nous des solutions
s'il ya des chemins qui ont échoué
montrer comment ce qu'on pourrait faire
mieux là ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'à
force de demander des têtes risquent de
se retrouver à la rue chaque banque mais
la même situation
parce qu'on n'a pas cherché de triche
pas de purges staliniennes dans le monde
de la santé
si je vous suis céline alors je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui mériterait quand
même de rendre compte
mais si vraiment pour avoir on donne je
préfère avoir des réponses et des
solutions des têtes coupées
ceux ci ont cherché les personnes qui
devraient rendre compte ce serait qui
mais moi j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on
revienne sur la question le témoignage
de monsieur salomon parce qu'à un moment
donné j'ai l'impression qu'il ya quand
même eu de graves failles administrative
j'aimerais bien que l'on creuse ces
questions là et je vous dis qu'on
établisse la matérialité des faits on a
des agents sont à des administrations
ces gens sont censés avoir des rats
pendant soixante c'est tony l'état des
lieux de ce qui se passe je pense qu'on
a des documents qui nous renseigneraient
j'aimerais beaucoup ces documents
émergents vous avez également utilisé
des des sigles on va donner la
traduction alors l'eprus c'est
l'établissement de préparation et de
réponse aux urgences sanitaires et les
ars ce sont les fameuses agences
régionales de santé
bertrand père y est votre point de vue
sur ce qui vient d'être dit peut-être
plus exactement le point de vue sur les
auditions qui qu'on a on qu'on a eu
depuis le début de les ouvrir sur
l'ouverture des travaux de la commission
d' enquête parlementaire
de didier raoul tas hier roselyne
bachelot et et marisol touraine
oui alors effectivement on est un peu là
avec la clarté aveuglante des visions
rétrospective puisque chacun ex post
essaye d'expliquer ce qu'il fallait
faire dans un moment où objectivement
personne ne le savait véritablement ce
qu'il ne fallait faire la déclaration de
roselyne bachelot on connaît bien
roselyne bachelot avait là des paroles
extrêmement libre puisque elle n'est
plus dans la vie politique est elle à
cette double casquette d'ancienne
ministre mais également de
professionnels de santé puisque chacun
sait que elle est pharmacienne et elle
dit elle même souvent que son grand
complexe c'est le grand complexe de
l'armoire vide et que ce qu'elle déteste
c'est d'avoir des armoires vidées
qu'elle revendique 7 sur commande de
vaccins qui n'était probablement pas
d'ailleurs une sur commande à l'époque
convient à beaucoup reproché pour
laquelle on l'a beaucoup moqué et en
fait ce ce débat sur la leurs proches de
aux médecins de ne pas avoir assuré eux
mêmes leur protection
on n'est pas très lointain d'un débat
qui est peut-être passé un peu inaperçu
mais que les avocats et puisque les
avocats aussi on était à court de
masques à un moment dans la période de
pénurie alors même que les avocats
interviennent comme vous le savez dans
des commissariats en garde à vue dans
des tribunaux à proximité de détenus
deux juges de greffier dans un
environnement de très grande proximité
puisque par hypothèse
les avocats ont besoin de communiquer
confidentiellement avec leurs clients
donc à une très proche distance et à
l'époque où on était dans une situation
de pénurie de masques
les avocats ont saisi le juge et plus
précisément un conseil d'état pour
obtenir des masques et du gel à l'époque
parce que c'était nécessaire à
l'exercice des fonctions de défense qui
encore une fois suppose un dialogue
extrêmement rapprochés et la seule
réponse que l'on a reçu du juge c'est
bah écoutez en fait il est normal que
l'état privilégie ses agents c'est à
dire les jus
les greffiers que dans une situation de
pénurie de masques et bien on a réservé
les masques aux agents de l'état et que
pour les professions indépendantes que
sont les avocats est bien la seule chose
que le juge a dit c est bien il
appartient seulement à l'état de faire
bénéficier les avocats des circuits
d'approvisionnement pour obtenir des
masses et donc pas en réalité les
avocats nous on s'est fourni à travers
les organisations représentatives par
des circuits d'approvisionnement et on
s'est fourni nous mêmes et on a acheté
des masques à nos salariés et on a
acheté des masques pour nos
collaborateurs et donc finalement on
s'est aussi retrouvé dans une situation
de disette
on ne la verra si je suis en est sorti
nous en sommes sortis parce que la
pénurie a cessé mais dans la période de
pénurie qui est celle qui évoque
roselyne bachelot on était dans la même
situation et on a pourvu nous-mêmes à
notre approvisionnement en masse
on a un certain nombre de réactions sur
vous pouvez en lire certaines d'ailleurs
sur le player et elles sont à côté de
nous sur le tchat
on va justement vous donner la parole je
salue notamment frisk et pragma la pop
l'os qui nous ont rejoints nicole
également le problème est que tous les
moyens ont été mis dans les hôpitaux et
on a laissé les libéraux face à la
pandémie
c'était la critique justement d'une
gestion qui a été hospitalisé entre et
comme vous le disais tout à l'heure
lucile nicole également qui nous dit
quand on voit les prestations de
bachelot après son retrait de la
politique on pose on peut se poser la
question de sa crédibilité c'est un
autre débat
roland vous nous dites les médecins et
leurs égos surdimensionnés n'approche
n'apprécie pas d'être recadrés on ne
touche pas à cette caste
alors que christophe naudi 41 morts chez
les médecins généralistes
roselyne bachelot pourrait avoir un peu
de retenue citoyens payeurs nous dit
manger mon généraliste m'a cronje en
2010 est donc n'a pas assez ne pas de
mots assez durs contre la république en
marche depuis quelques mois curieux
édifiant la perte de confiance et
frisquet lui estime même qu on pourrait
monter jusqu'à 200 le nombre de médecins
morts des suites du coronavirus juste
peut-être avant 2 avant de clore ce
débat entre effectivement d'un côté les
médecins qu'ils n'accepteraient pas la
critique et des politiques qui
n'auraient pas assez de retenue votre
point de vue fergane mais au risque de
me répéter je pense qu'elle est la
critique adressée aux médecins est
injustifiée parce que pour reprocher aux
médecins de ne pas s'être procuré
suffisamment de masse encore faut-il
encore aurait-il fallu que le commerce
de masques soit ce moment là libre et
légal ce qui n'était pas puisqu'on avait
une doctrine de restriction marquisienne
on à en appliquer une logique de
rationnement en disant qu'il fallait
absolument réserver les masques aux
personnels de l'état et bertrand taille
et l'a rappelé tout à l'heure il ya une
doctrine restrictive or je suis désolé
de faire encore une fois monté au riz
siens d'économies sur un ton professoral
mais quand vous êtes en première année
d'économie on vous apprend que le
malthusianisme réduire comme ça
artificiellement la possibilité pour les
consommateurs de se procurer de
marchandises rares saad hui un tas
d'effets pervers parce que vous
perturber en fait les signaux de marché
destinés au tri qui permettra à
l'appareil productif de s'adapter à une
demande qui explose soudainement
or le l'atavisme je pensais à terre
derrière les valises fergane à tous les
parents de familles nombreuses
mais qui ne sont pas mal fusil à paris
peut-être ils l'ont prouvé
exactement c'est pour ça que c'était
sans pardon je vous ai coupés mais on a
on a compris quelle était votre votre
point de vue sur la sur la question on a
posé la question justement aux
internautes sur twitter et sur youtube
sur cette polémique
roselyne bachelot at elle raison de
dénoncer l'attitude des médecins sur la
pénurie de masques et d'où cette
agression qu on vous posait sur twitter
vous avez continué de voter pendant le
débat mais on a observe les mêmes
tendances vous êtes partagés
une légère majorité en tous cas ceux qui
ont voté légère majorité dit non elle
n'a pas raison mais c'est à 50,3 % voilà
pour cette question on y reviendra on
n'a pas abordé la question qui est
l'autre polémique fait didier rahout et
les hôpitaux les hôpitaux de paris mais
vous pouvez justement retrouver tous les
termes de la polémique du débat les
règles
les réponses dans sur le site du figaro
où on revient largement sur cette
dernière polémique entre le professeur
marseillais et l'ancien membre du
gouvernement fillon martin hirsch
napoléon n'est pas content c'est
napoléon 30 exactement puisque c'est son
pseudo
le nom du compte figaro qui l'utilisent
où il a wheel et s'est dit remonté
contre l'attitude des plateformes
honteux où est la liberté d'expression
c'est son commentaire c'est votre
commentaire n'a pas liée à ce communiqué
de youtube qu'on va retrouver après
avoir mis